jada pinkett smith breaks her silence
about the oscar slap heard around the
world
oh wow before we get into what jada said
let me get you up to speed on sunday the
actress's husband will smith struck
chris rock live on stage at the 2022
oscars for making this joke about her
shaved head jada i love you g.i jane 2
can't wait to see it all right
the problem with that joke well the 50
year old red table talk host has been
pretty vocal about her struggle with
alopecia and autoimmune disorder which
causes bald spots and hair loss and
based on that eye roll it was pretty
clear she wasn't laughing and neither
was will
oh wow
wow
will smith just smacked out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i jane jump keep my
fast forward to tuesday and jada is
speaking out posting this simple message
to instagram which reads this is a
season for healing and she's here for it
it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations
with kindness
and consideration
of course the girls trip star's message
comes after will broke down in tears
accepting the award for best actor for
his portrayal as venus and serena
williams dad richard williams in king
richard
richard williams
was a fierce
defender of his family
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees at the time will apologized to
the academy and his fellow nominees but
notably didn't say sorry to chris
thank you uh
hokkien academy invites me back thank
you but by monday he changed his tune by
posting this statement on instagram that
violence in all of its forms is
poisonous and destructive quote my
behavior at last night's academy awards
was unacceptable and inexcusable jokes
at my expense are a part of the job but
a joke about jada's medical condition
was too much for me to bear and i
reacted emotionally jaina i love you g.i
jane 2 can't wait to see it all right
the 53-year-old actor also apologized to
the comedian directly i was out of line
and i was wrong i am embarrassed and my
actions were not indicative of the man i
want to be there is no place for
violence in a world of love and kindness
will went on to say he was sorry to the
academy the show's producers attendees
the viewers at home and the williams
family i deeply regret that my behavior
has stained what has been an otherwise
gorgeous journey for all of us i am a
work in progress
art imitates life i look like the crazy
father just like they said
i look like crazy father just like they
said about richard williams
um
but love will make you do crazy things
well on monday richard williams shared
his two cents telling e.t in a statement
that while he doesn't know all the
details of what happened he doesn't
condone anyone hitting anyone else
unless it's in self-defense even will's
mother carolyn bright spoke out about
the incident during an interview with a
local philadelphia news station he
is a very
even
people person and that's the first time
i've ever seen him go off
the first time
in his lifetime it surprised you too huh
it did it did as i said i've never seen
him
do that but all of the drama aside she
said she's still proud of her son i know
how
he works
how hard he works
and he never half steps and just to see
him and i've been waiting and waiting
and waiting and
when i heard the name i was just
yes
[Music]